first time you see him you walk away
saying while he does things normal
players even elite players struggle to
do I've seen it one other time Derek
loves everybody likes to see his gang
like to see him doing special dunk my
mom is about 64 years old and she told
me last night she says Travis she says
me your daddy pull it over on the side
of the street and we saw the Malik dunk
over two people out there
last time we measured the leaks vertical
it was a 37 inch vertical he has next
man hops if this person is jumping this
high he's jumping higher he is gifted in
his eyes lettuces
I just don't want to get to the yay I
mean everybody gets to be a I want to
have a homegoing career and just be one
of the best because we're not the best I
don't know why you play
Lepanto Arkansas is the place in
Northeast Arkansas in the Delta blue
collar you know hard-working Lepanto is
like a small town everybody knows each
other
Malik and his family live in the woods
it's not a wooded community it's just
part of Lepanto I don't know how I
became the woods I don't know if it's
cause it's the last three streets where
the blacks live or you could just feel
at home in the woods as close as Lepanto
is the woods is even closer we're small
but we're dominant and we got hard and
you see it when my league play
and back behind the house before the
park I mean it was just my friend so
younger people so I guess a killing one
time in our community the kids don't get
to play with the adults until you until
you get of a certain age I'll use the
one to play with the grown folks but
they never let me play so I just had to
work hard then when they finally let me
play sorry I started killing he got to
play with the adults very early meaning
he was good early now you know it's he's
that guy now and he's telling those
younger kids now to get off the court
but that's just something that you know
we all go through
I think was the hardest thing doing my
life took to leave a Penta that I loved
he loved being out here I just loved it
and I I really didn't think I was gonna
move into the you heart guy here we
started loading everything good
plan on on a lower level really wasn't
going to advance him any but if he could
go to this next level and play and do
well then it gave him higher potential
of being able to be who he is today from
leaks to come to Bentonville and for
what that meant for our program for us
it's allowed us to do things like kids
who are high school players that are
just that's the end of the road for them
they've got to travel the United States
and play and these showcase tournaments
and games against guys who are future
NBA players even though people were
upset with us leaving Lepanto I just
done it for my family
everybody like a you coming home I said
no Malik
when Malik graduate I might come home
but until the end with Malik neither
could represent Lepanto so he represent
he mentioned it and talked about the
woods in everything you do I want many
people here proud because everybody had
my back when I was younger
everybody knew I was I was thinking I
think everybody knew I was gonna be good
and I just want to see them happy
you